non non mais et et c'est fou parce que
tu tu tu te retrouves tu dévoiles que tu
es en 2012 que tu es SDF depuis 1 an on
avait pas de nouvell de toi et nous pour
c'est vrai que les les les les les les
personnes bah moi je regardais voilà je
te regardais et c'est vrai que pour nous
voilà on disait c'est une énorme star
comment elle peut se retrouver SDF j'ai
pas j'ai j'ai demandé de l'aide à
personne ouais quand mais quand on m'a
enlevé mes enfants le 18 juillet 2011 je
me suis écroulé çaà dire écrouleré de
douleur hein j'étais à ramper par terre
à hurler comme une bête j'ai plus pu
organiser le quotidien j'avais un un
monsieur de la CAF qui m'avait visité
l'année d'avant qui m'avait vu au milieu
de mes enfants et qui m'avait refait une
visite parce qu'il y a des visites de
contrôle de la CAF comme j'étais à la
CAF il m'a dit mais qu'est-ce qui vous
arrive madame Nataf mais dans quel état
vous êtes je me suis écroulé et je pense
que c'est le fait qu'on m enlevé mes
enfants ça a été comme un coup de fusil
qu'on m'a c'est le c'est un coup de
fusil qu'on m'a qu'on m'a qu'on m'a
donné quoi je je j'étais une mère au
foyer je ne faisais que ça je ne faisais
que m'occuper de mes enfants je vivais
avec eux j'allais les chercher à l'école
je leur préparais à manger je faisais
leurs devoirs j'organisais leurs
vacances leur sortiese je je j'étais
j'avais trois enfants j' FAM il était où
le le le le le père du enfin de ton
troisème mari il été où à ce moment-là
euh il a fait deux AVC ah d'accord ouis
deux AVC coup sur coup d'accord donc
c'estàdire quand on nous a enlevé les
enfants 15 jours après il est tombé par
terre ah ouais il bavait il bavait enfin
de la bave de de de de de son avesser il
a pas voulu aller se faire contrôler par
le médecin et 15 jours après il en a ref
second ça a été ça a été l'enfer quoi
l'enfer et donc et et et et donc toi tu
te retrouves quoi tu te retrouves seul
tu te retrouves seul à la rue avec mon
bébé mon bébé qui venait de naître dans
cet appartement sans mes enfants j'ai
pas supporté d'avoir l'appartement sans
les enfants j'avais une petite dette de
loyer que qui qui était réglé par le FSL
le fond de solidarité logement j'ai même
pas pu aller chercher le chèque et donc
quoi tu et tu t'es dit je vais aller je
vais aller non j'ai rien dit du tout
j'ai laissé les choses couler le 16 mars
est arrivé le le la fin de la trêve
hivernale j'ai été hébergée par une amie
qui habitait dans le 16e qui m'a hébergé
40 jours et 40 jours après j'avais pas
d'autre solution j'avais coupé tous les
points avec ma famille parce que dans le
procès qui m'avait opposé au père il y
avait eu des problèmes avec ma famille
donc les ponts avaient été coupés
entièrement j'étais seule au monde avec
mon bébé et le père de mes enfants à la
suite de de mon troème enfant à la suite
de ces deux AVC n'était plus en capacité
de gérer quoi que ce soit donc on s'est
pris un coup de bambou sur la tête et et
et et je me suis laissée glisser je me
comment ça se passe tu te retrouvesé
Gliss tu te retrouves dans la rue avec
ton ton enfant euh qu'est-ce comment
raconte-nous c'est quoi ta vie à ce
moment-là ben je j'avais ma poussette et
et et je me promenais dans Paris je
faisais visiter les monuments les
monuments de Paris à mon fils et la nuit
je trouvais des endroits dans des dans
des dans des parkings dans des dans des
des petits squir où je restais quand le
squir était fermé dans la poussette
j'avais une poussette magique dans
lequel il y avait tout sa nourriture
c'est son change il était bébé il avait
6 mois donc c'était vraiment un TR pas
peur d'être dans la rue comme ça avec un
enfant oh non j'ai jamais eu peur de
rien vraiment tu étais ou je je j'ai
toujours avancé dans la vie quoi que
j'ai eu à vivre que ce soit tout en haut
ou tout en bas j'ai avancé quoi j'ai
avancé j'ai marché j'ai avancé ouais et
tu as tu as dû faire tu as d tu as fait
des rencontres tu as fait des non non je
me suis tenu loin de tout le monde j'ai
vécu dans une solitude intense les gens
te reconnaissaient ou pas est-ce qu' y
avait des gens qui te de temps en temps
des gens reconnaissaient les gens
étaient très délicats très très très
inquiet très très
bienveillant on me donnait de l'argent
tous les jours je n'ai jamais tendu la
main j'ai jamais mis un petit pot les
gens venaient pour me mettre de l'argent
dans la main et il me donnent quand même
entre 20 et 30 € par jour donc ce qui
est conséquent enfin en tout cas
suffisamment pour prendre mon café pour
faire ma laaverie pour renouveler mes
affaires très régulièrement pour acheter
ce qu'il fallait pour l'enfant quand
j'étais avec l'enfant je suis restée 6
mois dehors avec lui hein ça n'a duré
que 6 mois sur les 10 années d'érance
mais il faut dire que j'ai travers 10
ans tu as passé 10 ans 10 ans 5 ans
pleins à la rue et 5 ans de petits
hébergements petits hébergements
incroyable 5 ans à la rue tu as passé 5
ans ou 5 ans plein et un moment tu étais
toute seule à la rue sans ton enfant
toute seule sans mon enfant il m'a été
retiré dans un commissariat dans le dos
il venait de me trouver un foyer donc ça
faisait 6 mois qu'on était dehors on
cherchait un foyer des gens des des
travailleurs sociaux venaient vers nous
mais il n' avait pas de solution le 115
on appelit le 115 en décembre sous la
neige et le 115 nous répondait non mais
je dis j'ai un petit bébé d'un an et
demi il faut pouvoir me loger il disait
non non nous n'avons plus de place tant
pis madame nous sommes désolés
rappelez-nous demain et on se retrouvait
sous la neige avec mon bébé je suis même
allé en Espagne j'ai fait un voyage en
Espagne avec lui j'ai pris le train
jusqu'en Espagne parce que je me disais
peut-être au soleil ça sera moins dur le
25 le 24 décembre au soir on s'est
trouvé dans un immeuble un très joli
immeuble que j'avais trouvé à
Barcelone les gens étaient en train
d'écouter les champs de Noël puisque
nous on était dehors donc j'entendais
les champs de Noël à travers la porte il
y a un monsieur qui est sorti et qui
nous il nigeait dehors et qui nous a dit
vous sortez maintenant madame ils
étaient en train d'écouter des chants de
Noël et ils nous ont fait sortir pendant
qu'ils écoutaient des champs de Noël
donc les les la vie est dure Cyril les
gens ont des priorités et malorinatf
n'était pas la priorité des gens et
quand les juges ont eu malorinataf entre
leurs mains ils ont ils ont ils ont
appuyé ils ont appuyé ouais vraiment tué
tu sentais tu as senti qu'il y avait
qu'il avait une de PO une for une forme
de revanche une forme de revanche ah oui
oui oui le au cours de mon procès
l'assistant du procureur général était
présent mon mari m'a dit mais même pour
Nicolas Sarkozi l'assistante du
procureur général ne se déplace pas j'ai
eu j'avais j'ai eu une un pic de
carrière qui était quand même très
conséquent donc se retrouver dans des
conditions où on a rien c'est là que
tout le monde sort le fusil en disant
bah on est bien content de l'avoir à
terre ouais est-ce que la bienveillance
et la bonté c'est pas forcément la
qualité la plus Ré pendu est-ce que
est-ce qu' a des moments quand tu t'as
on te prend ton ton fils quand tu te
retrouves seul à la rue qu'est-ce que tu
te dis à ce moment tu te dis pas je vais
est-ce que tu as eu des des des des ah
je me dis voilà c'est dur d'en parler
c'est c'est c'est dur d'en parler c'est
c'est c'est j'ai vécu 10 ans à hurler
comme un comme une bête qu'on égorge
pendant 8 ans je n'ai pas supporté c'est
comme si ma vie s'était arrêtée cet
instant où j'ai accompagné mes enfants à
la porte leur parents est leur Parin est
venu les chercher et j'ai vu le visage
de mon mon fils disparaît derrière la
porte et le visage de ma fille disparaît
derrière la porte ma vie est restée
arrêtée à cet instant pendant 8 ans
pendant 8 ans je hurlais dehors il
m'arrivait de temps en temps je me
mettais à hurler comme une bête j'étais
dehors et je me mettais à hurler
tellement la douleur j'avais
l'impression qu'on pressait mon cœur à
chaque seconde pendant 8 ans maintenant
ça y est j'ai réussi à faire le deuil de
de ma vie d'avant de mes enfants de ma
vie de famille on était cinq à la maison
il y avait trois enfants mon mari et moi
et on s'est retrouvé tous les trois
comme des cons sans les petits on
m'avait pris mes petits on m'a pris mes
petits maintenant je n'en veux à
personne ce sont je considère que c'est
ma destiné je le prends comme un un coup
du sort je devais traverser ça en est où
en ce moment avec tes enfants et ce je
revois mon grand mon grand je le vois
très très régulièrement il a 25 ans
maintenant il est chauffeur ubert d'cord
d'accord ma fille qui est plus délicate
plus raffinée plus sensible souhaite ne
pas avoir de contact pour le moment pour
elle c'est trop difficile elle quel âge
elle a 22 ans d'accord et mon dernier il
est toujours placé à la zeu il a il est
dans la même famille d'accueil depuis
qu'il a 2 ans et demi il en a 14 c'est
un petit bagarur un petit un petit
garçon un peu un peu fort un peu un peu
voilà qui qui est qui roule un peu des
mécaniques je l'ai revu une fois il y a
3 mois et je dois le revoir aujourd'hui
un peu plus tard dans la journée alors
en 2018 tu annonces ne plus être SDF
depuis un an et demi et début 2019 tu
recommences à renêre sur la scène
mdiatique et tu tombes dans les mystères
de l'amour euh et
en 2020 on te retrouve on te retrouve
SDF qu'est-ce qui s'est passé entre 2019
et ben la veille du covid j'étais dans
un café je j'avais vécu 2 ans et demi en
colocation à ici les moulinau une
colocation qui avait pris fin parce que
le monsieur avec lequel j'habitais
attendait son sa retraite et il m'avait
dit quand j'aurai ma retraite j'aurais
suffisamment de moyens pour ne plus
avoir à louer une chambre donc on se
quittera donc au bout de 2 ans et demi
on était arrivé à la fin de ce cette
collaboration cette collocation et et
j'avais pas suffisamment de moyens pour
me louer un appartement c'est très cher
de Louin un appartement il faut des
fiches de salaire il faut des feuilles
d'impôt j'avais pas tout ça donc je
logeais à l'hôtel dans un petit hôtel à
40 € la nuit et la veille du covid mais
vraiment la veille de covid à 16h
j'étais dans un café passage du Havre du
côté des galeries lafillette je prenais
un petit thé et je me suis levé pour
parce qu'il y avait des garçons qui
faisaient beaucoup de bruit à côté de
moi donc je me suis levé avec ma tasse
de thé pour aller un peu plus loin et
j'ai laissé mon sac sur ma chaise et
quand je suis revenue m'asseoir pour
payer il y avait les deux gar garçon
n'était plus là et il y avait plus mon
portefeuille et dedans il y avait 450 €
il y avait ma pièce d'identité ma ma
carte de banque je me suis dit bah c'est
pas grave pour ce soir je payerai pas la
chambre d'hôtel je la payerai demain
j'irai à la banque oui mais le lendemain
c'est le confinement donc je me retrouve
seul à nouveau sans argent non mais
quand ça veut pas ça veut pas quand ça
veut pas ça veut pas j'étais pas à la
fin du cycle et je me retrouve à nouveau
dans les mêmes conditions alors Jean-Luc
m'a dit pourquoi ne nous as-tu pas
appelé oui d'abord un il y avait j'avais
t mes toutes mes affaires tout mon
carnet d'adresse mon portable tout était
dans mon dans la petite pochette qui
m'avait volé et puis je me suis dit bon
ben tant pis j'y retourne c'est c'est un
coup du sort bon bah là pass passé le
confinement à la rue ah mais passé le
confinement le confinement il a duré un
an et demi ou ça il vous rester dans la
rue ben je suis restée dans la rue oui
j'avais plus la force au bout d'un
moment vous savez quand ça fait 10 ans
que les difficultés s'accumulent vous
avez plus la force donc je me suis
laissé je me suis dit bon bah voilà
c'est c'est un coup du sort et là pour
le coup j'ai été très féminine dans le
sens où j'avais pas la la patate de me
dire oui je vais y arriver je vais m'en
sortir je vais faire ce qu'il faut je me
disais bon ben il faut croire que ça
doit être ça ma vie je l'accepte et je
me suis rassise sur ma bouche de chaleur
en attendant que le temps passe jusqu'à
ce que vous fassiez l'émission et en
fait quand vous avez fait l'émission Ça
a déclenché des gens très dangereux qui
sont venus vers moi quand vous avez fait
le le spécial sur moi des hommes
vraiment de très mauvaise qual qui sont
venus vers moi et le préfet a eu peur ah
d'accord ah ouais donc le préfet a fait
un arrêté préfectoral pour m'enlever de
dehors et j'ai et ils m'ont dit la seule
solution que nous avons pour vous parce
que nous ne pouvons pas vous loger parce
qu'à chaque fois il y avait pas de
logement les Marreau d'elle passai la
Croix Rouge non désolé madame Nataf il y
a pas de logement on peut pas vous aider
on a rien de disponible pour vous et
vers la fin il y avait une femme de la
Mairie de Paris qui s'est intéressée à
mon dossier Corine teb et qui avait fini
par me trouver quelque quelque chose
mais j'étais plus en capacité d'écouter
j'étais plus en capacité d'écouter il y
a un moment donné quand vous êtes seul
parce que j'étais vraiment très seule
dehors quand vous êtes là poser 15h par
jour à méditer à attendre que le temps
passe aller boire vos cafés j'avais un
rythme euh aller à la douche euh laver
ses affaires être propre manger trois
fois par jour vous êtes occupé à faire
le minimum et ce minimum il remplit vos
journées donc vous n'imaginez pas que il
peut y avoir un éclaircissement et qu'on
va vous aider puisque personne ne vous a
aidé donc vous pensez que bah c'est
comme ça c'est ma vie on ne m'aide pas
et donc votre émission a déclenché
l'hôpital psychiatrique donc je me suis
retrouvée à l'hôpital psychiatrique et
là l'hôpital psychiatrique il m'a dit
ils m'ont dit écoutez madame Nataf si
vous voulez pas rester longtemps chez
nous trouvez un logement et c'est là que
j'ai rappelé mon père d'accord
c'est-à-dire au bout de 12 ans de où les
ponts avaient été coupés j'ai dit là
j'ai pas le choix je pas rester enfermé
comme ça pendant des années parce qu'ils
m'ont dit on vous garde nous hein si
vous avez pas quelque chose on vous
garde il y a pas de limite de temps donc
j'ai appelé mon père et j'ai dit papa
fais Fiss ça parce que là vraiment
l'hôpital psychiatrique c'est vraiment
pas drôle je fais le tour du jardin je
clope je vais pas rester là et je suis
restée 4 mois à l'hôpital et 5 mois dans
ce qu'ils appellent une une une clinique
post cure c'est-à-dire pour voir que le
comportement est bien stabilisé et que
la personne est prête à rentrer dans la
vie et à vivre une vie normale et là
j'ai mon père m'a loué un appartement et
donc depuis novembre 2022 je suis logée
euh 20 oui c'est ça de novembre 2022
j'ai un contrat de location mon à mon
nom et mon loyer n'est pas très élevé il
est de 850 € donc je peux assumer ma vie
seu voilà par moi-même c'est incroyable
en 2021 tu témoignis dans un reportage
te montrais ta ta vie dehors ça faisait
mal au cœur c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
ensuite qu'on s'est on a voulu te
recevoir regarder c'était il y a de
jours malorine natf nous emmène sur les
traces de son errance mtro dit meuble ou
encore ce parking elle dit avoir vécu
dans la rue avec son enfant de 2 ans et
demi et la dernière fois que j'ai dormi
dans ce parking j'ai dormi là voilà
alors je venez venez venez toutes les
affaires que j'avais y compris la
poussette je mettais tout devant la
voiture ce qui fait que quand le gardien
il se présente bah il voit rien les 3
mois que j'ai vécu ils ont été plus
intenses que les 35 dernières années de
ma vie hein jour après jour je me disais
je vais pas faire le jour d'après pour
être très honnête le 13 janvier 2022 il
y a des images qui sont sorties aussi on
te voit seul rudrivoli à Paris assis sur
une grille d'ahération du métro ça
c'était des images qui nous ont fait
extrêmement mal ici aussi hein parce
qu'on les avait revu
[Musique]
regarder quel part ou pas j'ai mal part
j'ai un peu mal à la tête à cause du
monsieur
[Musique]
ça c'est dur de revoir ces ces images je
suis punk
je suis punk cy c'estàdire que j'ai j'ai
eu une vie de punk moi ici on n pas dans
un sur un territoire anglo-saxon les
Anglo-Saxons il comprendrai peut-être un
peu mieux moi je suis une punk
c'est-à-dire que j'ai une vie bourgeoise
je suis née dans une famille bourgeoise
mais il y a quelque chose dans ma
personnalité je suis une écorch et vive
j'ai j'ai j'ai eu une vie avec des hauts
des bas j'ai vu j'ai vu des choses que
peu de gens sur terre voient j'ai eu
l'occasion d'expérimenter des choses que
peu de gens exp ente à tous les niveaux
de ma vie que ce soit au niveau
personnel au niveau familial au niveau
professionnel au niveau sentimental j'ai
eu une vie de roller coaster quoi et et
j'ai toujours pris les choses comme elle
m'arrivaient quand c'était tout en haut
bah c'était tout en haut c'était tout en
bas c'était tout en bas je suis il y a
peut-être une forme de passivité aussi
et c'est en ça que je dis que le féminin
a peut-être aussi pris le dessus parce
que je suis pas une working girl je suis
une fille plutôt douce plutôt calme
plutôt tranquille on me donne un coup de
point moi je ne réponds pas on m'a fait
des choses dans ma vie je n'ai jamais
attaqué personne je n'ai jamais déposé
une plainte de ma vie je n'ai jamais
attaqué qui que ce soit malgré tout ce
que j'ai reçu tout ce que l'on m'a fait
et toutes les tous les problèmes que
j'ai pu avoir je n'ai jamais attaquer
personne donc c'est aussi une question
de personnalité j'ai quelque chose comme
ça de d'oriental je j'ai une partie j'ai
50 % de mon ADN qui est orientale et il
y a quelque chose comme ça du laisser
être du laisser vivre du laisser passer
euh qui me définit aussi j'ai pas eu euh
comme on dit on donne un coup de talon
pour s'en sortir j'ai pas ce ce cet
instinct survie là de cette façon-là je
n'ai pas eu alors euh Jean-Luc euh
comment vous avez renoué contact avec
Malorie parce que c'est c'est on l'a
cherché pendant longtemps d'accord alors
il y a d'une part des des des copains de
la série qui l'ont cherché qui l'ont
parfois retrouvé mais ell ne voulaiit
rien entendre euh les les les gens de la
boîte la chercher aussi et puis un jour
euh on l'a retrouvé et je lui ai demandé
si elle voulait revenir dans les
mystères de l'amour et elle m'a dit oui
je veux bien donc elle est revenue ça a
duré 3 4 mois oui c'est ça puis a eu le
covid et là ensuite plus de nouvell
impossible la joindre et on a appris
qu'elle était dans la rue et là
impossible de la retrouver et ensuite
quand et là ouais quand elle allait
mieux j'ai appelé maorie un jour elle
m'a répondu j'ai dit comment tu vas elle
m'a dit je vais beaucoup mieux est-ce
que tu veux reprendre les mystères
deamour me dit là je me sens pas capable
encore parce que j'ai pris trop de
médicaments trop de choses il faut que
je retrouve ma mémoire voilà et puis
elle m'a rappelé quelques mois après al
ça est je peux reprendre les mystère et
donc là elle elle revient dans les
mystères de l'amour elle a commencé à
Noël et en janvier elle sera là
incroyable
al tu as fait